this is just the best I think you're
gonna like this Ted Cruz liked a very
explicit porn video on Twitter
very late last night a two-minute porn
video from the account sexual post
sexual with two L's the porn video shows
a woman walking in on a man and another
woman having sex on a couch was in Ted
Cruz's liked Twitter posts for at least
30 minutes before being unliked sometime
around 1:00 a.m. and thanks to this Ted
Cruz was trending globally on Twitter
throughout the night and you will see
what do we have here for people to look
at yes Ted Cruz is like of this video
you'll notice that sexual posts also
updated their Twitter profile to stay
follow the same porn as Ted Cruz watches
that is just great response from Ted
Cruz's communications director Catherine
Fraser well it appears I guess that
something happened to Ted Cruz's account
she tweeted out this is amazing the
offensive tweet posted on Ted Cruz's
account earlier has been removed by
staff and reported to Twitter what
exactly is there to report to Twitter I
mean the implication must be that
someone took control of Ted Cruz's
account and did nothing other than like
a single porn video that's what you have
to believe some hacker took control of a
senator's Twitter account didn't post a
political message didn't change Ted
Cruz's profile didn't do anything other
than liking a single porn video very
late at night I mean I guess there are a
number of explanations to this maybe it
actually was hacked maybe it was some
low-level staffer who had access to the
account but it seems like whenever
there's these sexual scandals when it
comes to politicians we just give them
the pass at first and then later and
later we find out more details and it
turns out to be true yeah like with the
Anthony Weiner stuff at first we thought
well they're just making fun of his last
name there's no way that's actually a
picture of him come to find out and
actually was isn't this may be the most
relatable and human action that Ted Cruz
has ever taken though like I can't think
of anything Ted Cruz is done that might
actually make someone say oh you know
what he's just kind of like your average
guy who doesn't really know how Twitter
works or something if there wasn't a
layer of hypocrisy here I wouldn't care
I would just find it pretty funny right
Ted Cruz against porn against sex shop
supposedly the Family Values Christian
conservative publicly recommending
pornography on social media to people at
some point there's always like a
conflicting impossible explanation so
right now there's an implication that
Ted Cruz's account was somehow hacked
later we'll hear the the responsible
intern was fired for this it's like well
hold on a second was the account hacked
or did an intern just do the wrong thing
thinking maybe they were logged into
their own account or something like that
and if Ted Cruz did do it did he not
know that his likes are public you know
it's not the same as repeating or you
know posting it or something but
probably didn't like sir public - right
I don't know he probably had no idea
that you can see if you like a video a
Twitter post I do believe though that
this is a huge step towards bridging the
political gap and tensions that we're
seeing under the Trump administration
when we can just all laugh at Ted Cruz's
technological incompetence I think it
will do a lot to further and support
bipartisan actions yes in our House and
Senate so I think for that we can all be
glad